[Applause]
yes hello everyone thank for for having
me it's really an honor to be in this
meter like the largest PI data yeah they
already spoke about me I've been in the
open-source community for quite a few
years in the Python 1/4 for 12 years
with more than 12 years my background is
in computer engineering and with a
master in AI as they say ty4 since a
couple of months now I'm been in the
pandas core development team I've been
contributing for more than a year
- fellow InFocus ambassador I organized
a London pythoness prints group I'll
talk a bit at the end if I have time and
I work full time as a data scientist a
disco and just quickly about pandas how
many you having used pandas yet - okay
so the first part would be a very short
and that's what I don't know Java stuff
to show reponders was was he started by
West McKinney in 2008 it's been 10 years
now he wanted just like to be able to do
what art does in in Python and from them
with a work for from many volunteers
it's been it's been growing what it is
now
Punda C is huge the API is really like
only serious our 325 methods or
attributes data frame almost as much it
supports natively without any any other
package or library like more than 14
different formats like of course like
CSV but like lots of office stuff and
yeah it's literally like if you check
the documentation of the API it's more
than 1,200 pages so it's really really
really huge it's estimated by the people
mainly from Khandava tried most of the
downloads and the pipe I own that
estimator having about 5 to 10 million
users which is quite a lot and as I said
it's developed by the community meaning
that it's very rare for core developers
to be paid for their work meaning that
you should be feeling the like
contributing if you think that panda has
something
improved and not expect any company in
Silicon Valley
to fix it if that's what you feel and
non focus is just an umbrella
organization that represents basically a
las like not all as as as the people
from the project Alice's community they
are the ones that reporting events like
like these conferences and and
everything so you don't see them focus
as someone external it's basically just
like the brand for for lower all our
community just a quick overview will be
be very fast with that as everybody here
knows about pandas and probably
everybody know here knows about the
Titanic dataset so and that is this
thing that you'll basically read CSV
even if it's really bad format but
everybody loves CSV so users get it you
can visualize then you can just check
how many missing values are in the H
column with a single line of code you
can impute them by the median with a
single line of code and check again that
it work well you can go quickly quick
visualizations on the distribution you
can even get rid of all layers if you
consider people over 65 for layers that
it offends it maybe but I wanted to show
you can like get rid of all layers in in
this data set in a single line of code
you can also group people in different
bins while people or all rows in
different bins also a single line of
code one in this time three to make it
look better but literally a line of code
you can also do nice visualization a
pivot table when you can in this case
I'm plotting like by gender not gender
by by a to H group and by the class word
people were traveling which was the
proportion of of women
this doesn't look quite nice so we can
just format and and rename things and
have as easily as one line of code for
everything so basically pandas provide
like a function for everything you need
so it's just like single line of code
for everything that you need to
transform your you
so this talk is million update on pandas
what's going on i'll go quite fast with
some of the things i don't know if any
of you has your story is still using the
alex method it wind abrogated for i
think over a year now it was a very
tricky api getting like a lot of magic
law can i lock are the right things for
for that panel is being deprecated I
don't know panel actually was the reason
off of pandas is they actually pandas is
short for panel data analysis and we're
getting rid of panel which is a bit
weird maybe we'll have to rename it to I
don't know another name there are
alternative for that basically mainly
the multi indexing off of pandas those
are not yet deprecated but there are
serious talks about the protec gating
like the sparse data frame I don't think
anyone is is using that except for
pandas get dummies does anyone use the
Panda
the pandas a sparse data frame except
for the get damaged okay I think that's
what I think we're going to duplicate
that for shoreline so yeah it's not as a
sparse as the name says it's like
compressed representation but it's not
as far as these these formats like the
coordinate format or something like that
and was never finished it's a bit buggy
and I think it's better to at some point
if someone has the interest and I think
it what idea that that this is
maintained hot child of pandas and they
spend a bit of time explaining why in
place equals true is also something that
we want to deprecate I don't know
exactly in which way I'm sure many of
you are using that and actually if you
were paying attention I use that in my
previous example so that was intentional
so let's see why this in place is
something this is basically what I've
shown before is the same exact time
example before except for showing
because checking the data and the
visualizations and not so I get the same
exact result as before and as you can
see I've got these this in place here so
basically this can be done in two
different ways the
I could assign the dfh to this and I can
avoid the in place so usually that's one
of the I mean it's it's possible to do
it in place sometimes you save a bit of
code but it's like the alternative is
quite easy but that's actually not the
alternative preferred alternative I
think that's like really the way that
within a panda should be should be
looking in the filter like just method
chaining or this sort of pipelines
that's exactly the same as this code
it's doing exactly the same thing like
this so you can read the CSV everything
that it's being returned is a data frame
so you can filter and before I was
filtering these layers or not or layers
I was just filtering all people for no
reason i i was assigning like we're in
like replacing the values for female
people and people with numbers to be
able to compute this means on this
percentage also for the age computing
the bins doing the pivot table and
renaming and the styling and and
everything so i'm doing exactly the same
thing and i'm doing this like i think
it's much more compact code so three
main reasons we will see them one-by-one
read a bit ability cons i think i'm not
sure how many of you are coming from a
programming background but readability
counts if you don't believe me just
import this from from python and you can
see here the team peter's basically
wrote something that really there's
enough Python that really tells you
what's a good idea what's not and so on
something funny because you thought
these import this and if you know that
this code actually is encrypted probably
does even funnier but the thing is that
this is very very good guidelines I
think the Python community there's a
it's it's really what it is today
because of many of these things there is
also another one that it says there
should be only one and only one obvious
way to do things that in place basically
it's breaking this principle to and
beautiful is better than ugly I think
the second code was more beautiful
there's a personal opinion but yeah so I
think that's that's going to the
interest of having better code so the
second one is lazy evaluation I'll go
quickly with that it's a bit tricky but
I don't know how many of you know about
generators if you know anything about
generate
you will know that this code generating
100 billion samples and some sick
sequential numbers I'm doing the square
number of them basically takes mainly
zero seconds it's immediate because
basically Python didn't do anything at
all and I have a very silly example to
illustrate why imagine that you are the
programmer I'm the Python interpreter
and you tell me I went you to go to
Japan and get one of these fancy cards
that wave they arm I go there I bring it
to you
and then when I arrive you say okay now
I want you to go to China and bring one
of these cuts because what I want is to
compare the Chinese ones with the
Japanese ones and immediately after that
you say okay that was not very smart
because I just went to Japan I was
nearby China and now I need to go back
there that was kind of very silly if you
tell me everything first I can plant
things and I can with them much more
efficient that's mainly what it's
happening here actually it's happening
in generators it's happening for
different reasons but basically this was
West to English is like knowing what you
want to do so this map object that is
being returned didn't do anything it's
just like recording what you want to do
so it's just knowing that you want me to
go to China and Japan and then when you
need this data it will be executed so
this lazy evaluation when needs applied
to pandas we have some things like this
these when sorting the values and I'm
taking the three first that's just
getting the three there are three bigger
values of a randomly generated million
examples that's cool but this it's the
same thing as if I want the three
telescopes from the three biggest books
from from this shelf and I sort all them
and then I check which one are the
threes that's not very efficient because
I can just check which are the three
first than that so if in pandas there is
a method in largest that shows basically
that if you do this operation without
shorting all your data and just going to
the three first it's much more efficient
this I think takes like one order of
magnitude less than it is 163 this is 25
milliseconds so it's literally like one
order of magnitude faster so by
understanding all the operations you can
optimize things if you really know all
they started that needs to be done by
this method chaining before doing
anything and only at the very end
you apply that you can start optimizing
the different tasks and something even
cooler you can start distributing this
is what the spark or bias pack does and
this is this is from dusk north from
Pius Park but if you know that I want to
go to Japan I want to go to China and
that you can optimize and you can decide
what are the sequence of things to do
which is the smart way to do and even
distribute it over a cluster of
computers so that's really like
something that would be nice and this in
place would be a problem for for doing
that in terms of doing this method chain
so these are some references because I'm
going a bit fast and you might want to
know more about generators about this
method chaining these IVs is a project
that I started to though these you will
have the slides you can feel free to
take pictures but you won't have time in
some cases so the last thing for these
in place is these memory copies if I
create a data frame with a nun and I do
an in-place and I feel a zero what you
expect is that you already have all this
data in memory and onyx don't imagine
now that we have two by two that it
doesn't really matter
imagine that you have a terabyte in a
terabyte in your memory and you need to
fill these these missing value of course
you don't want to copy this memory you
want to go to the memory go to the place
where this is missing unfilled that's
quite simple and in place you just this
this is the idea of in place but what
happens if instead of going and filling
with a zero you fill with a stream or
something else the in place is not as in
place because pandas is tricking just
will go very briefly I don't have time
to go to the details but I will provide
more references as well when you
represent data in pandas or in a
computer in general the there are
different ways of representing this is
not just a silly example showing number
79 in different representations if you
have an unsigned int of 8-bit you will
have this first number if you have sign
in with 32-bit you will have disorder
and float64 it's of course 64 bits you
have a Python object it's actually what
you will have in bandar is a memory
pointer to a Python object that it's it
has different attribute a reference
count and not that something
internal of Python but it's really what
it's what you will have in memory if you
have a string representing this you will
have a different representation numpy
what it does is takes one of these types
and create an array of values so it's
like saying okay now I decided that I
have float64 and I won 1000 of them so
it takes a big chunk of memory it
assigns a type to it and it assigns a
shape and that's basically what numpy
does and then of course all the
operations you can do and this is a bit
tricky because the data is a terezinha
so internally what pandas cos is an
oompa array for every different type
it's this isn't in the block manager and
it's quite a big mess and the thing is
that they work the way computers work
these different blocks of memory every
time you need to change the size of the
type of this memory you need to get new
memory from the operating system and
drop what you have in here so if I want
to add an integer column to this data
frame in this integer block I need to
add a new column but it's not like
adding a new column as simple as that
you need to basically create a new a new
block that it's the same size as this
one plus a column move all the data
there fill the new column and then get
rid of that that's basically how whole
pandas works and it's quite a difficult
problem to solve the way that that
things work so that's when I just say so
what is this important like what is a
problem copying this memory and being
allocating these new memory getting rid
of it and copying it and they are
locating it because processors the speed
of processors has been increasing like
crazy this is disasters from the 80 it's
been increasing quite a lot but they the
speed of memory the speed of accessing
to memory
it hasn't increase as much as CPUs so
most of the times your program is not as
as low as your CPU can process it does
as low as you can bring data from the
memory to the CPU or make the memory
operations computers nowadays are mainly
memory bounded and this is a problem
when when you have these operations on
allocating memory and making copies of
your data
there is a there is an operation it
really well it's a problem in terms of
performance your results will be the
same but it will take much much longer
so going to this example this is the
example I had before I've had a missing
value and I have live like these float
values and what happens here what they
were saying if I fill with a value with
a value that it's a string
I had a block a single block that it was
two by two now I have one block that
it's float and another block that they
in subject this means that all my memory
basically I had to allocate again and
copy the data from the previous block to
the new blocks and then they allocate
again this is quite expensive and the
thing is that this in place gives the
intuition that this is not really what
what should be happening yeah I'm not
quite sure exactly which would be the
new API for that it's still under
discussion but this in place I would
personally avoid using it much unless
you really know what you're doing but in
some cases if you are feeling value that
doesn't have involve memory copies
that's the best way but in in some cases
if you are doing only for the syntax is
not so the thing is that the block
develop manager prevents that in place
operations are in place in terms of
making in place of the memory this
implies true means in place two means
doesn't mean that the memory is not
being copied so it can be misleading in
this way and actually there is a you can
when you are doing the other syntax that
you are just assigning you can just
assign a reference and not the whole
object so you can still have the same
results as in place you can plan in
place in memory operation and and still
have these other syntax that allow you
for for pipelines and that you have here
more references the second one is a
totally gave
explaining all this stuff much more in
detail at a trial data London this year
at the conference and just in case
you're guessing West McKinney say that
site by this year the more you know
about the Python
the pandas dataframe internals the more
horrified you are quite wrong um where's
McKenna can say that because he actually
is not that much active in pandas itself
in terms of coding because he started a
new project that is Apache ro that it's
basically a replacement for the block
manager instead of doing these three key
hacks we've we've with non PI to be
suitable to a two for iteration use data
in in pandas he is working on something
it's a C++ project the idea is that it
can be reused both by pandas and R and
any other in your library it's an open
standard so it's even JavaScript
implementation so at some point maybe
people from JavaScript will be able to
do data science in a similar way as
Python except for the really bad syntax
of the language you have more
information about ro in in these links
and details are oh it's already a stable
product it's already used in pandas but
not as our packing is used mainly for
transferring data to body BC uses that
and you get one order of magnitude
improvement in terms of a speed compared
to PI ODBC but using the buffers of varo
when you import data from PI spark to
pandas in the latest version it's using
arrow to to make it faster per cat if
you don't know it's a really fast format
for storing data is like kind of a CSP
but in a binary format that it's much
much faster in in many ways whereas this
carrying was created a lab that got
financing from some companies to hire
people to work full-time and open source
so if you know anyone or yourself that
it's really good at c++ and really
passionate about open source just feel
free to to apply and some other things
happening in pandas it's of course a
mature project as we saw and huge raise
a lot of is to have in terms of fixing
automating processes for the release and
tests and and things like that
cleaning all the applications you saw
also staying up to date with a new
version like making sure it is
compatible with python 3.7 there are
interesting things for since python 3.6
dictionaries are sorted actually in 315
python 3.7 it's when they are guaranteed
to be sorted but in Python 3 days not
six they are torrent it there are
something like for example when you
create a data frame from dictionaries if
you're in Python
not six on I hope you are you will get
the columns in the right order also when
you are assigning you can do fancy
things like assign a variable based on
the date on the data frame and in the
second one this one is using the one
that it's created in the previous record
keyword arguments are like dictionaries
so if you are previous to 3.6 they are
not sorted so they will be executed in
any random order if you're in 3.6 this
will be executed on ordered so the
assign method would be able to chain
things that you can be computing one
variable based on the one that users
defined then dropping python to support
this is happening this is happening in
in four month and a half in 2019 pandas
is not supported the same for noon time
at lip and that I like the whoo-hoo
so you know in cyber I was diagnosed in
this year it was a big run of applause
after that and I will explain your wife
does just to contextualize Python 3 has
so many amazing features you're still as
in the last versions and some of the
ones I like it's like plenty of stuff
it's quite difficult to tell this number
is hundred million but you know it
because it's the same as the one and
afterwards and this is quite obvious
that it's hundred million that's only
possible in path from 3.6 or four after
a few strings if you want to have a
string like a variable inside of a
string in Python 2 you just to do that
in Python 3 it supports these two things
like doing these two different versions
in Python 3.6 and later you can simply
add this F here and if the variable is
defined or even for expressions you
could say like what I want to spend time
but you can even have expressions in in
here inside the brackets and it will it
will execute things like double
unpacking in Python all versions of
Python if you want to get like the three
elements for a list like this first two
and the last one you need to do
something like this in the newest
versions you I think
is from Python 3.4 I'm not quite sure
it's been there for a while and you can
just say like get the first the second
the last and everything in the middle
get into this variable name in this card
so there are lots of critical things and
they're just like a sample there is lots
of other cool things the next thing is
that for you for you you have these when
you are in Python 3.6 you have all these
filters your code there starts to look
much better what's the problem we pandas
and other libraries your code is not
getting better it's getting actually
worse because you're supporting Python 2
which means that something that in
Python 3 it would be something as simple
as that you need to be compatible with
python 2 so your code starts to have
this compiled at the string tight
compare the string length so you can you
need to start writing functions that
basically replicate depending on the
language and even worst cases if it's
compatible your version with python 3.6
you run one thing if it's company if
it's not compatible you need to have the
old implementation so actually it's
making things much worse accordion
appears actually in to spend a lot of
time just making things and the code
looks much much worse so I think Python
Python dropping support for Python 2 it
means that only not only your code would
be better because Python is getting
better but on so Python Python code
pandas code would would get better and
all the other libraries so I I had the
same as like before just in case you
feel like giving this run of applauses
inside by
I'm glad you're excited about it
so extension arrays that they main
development i will go fast as the rest
of the talk but this is a as i said
nobody is being used in for representing
the data in pandas if we have a non pipe
what we have simply is like internal it
would be stored as a as a as a non pipe
if we check these values this is
representing like they the same value in
on Pyun not much happen because actually
pandas is already in representing this
internally there are other types like
category for example that they are not
as obvious and if you check values this
is not a numpy anymore because known pi
doesn't have the concept category so for
awhile it's been different things like
date times with time zones that is not
supported by non pi categories and
things like that so recently this is
basically how is the representation it's
in this case it's being repeated it's
being it's been represented by non pi
but by two different arrays one for the
indices and one for the for their labels
for the categories tom from the pandas
core development team implemented
something named cypher pandas that it's
an extension of pandas for working with
a type IP so a peas are specific we have
internal types of a specific type of
representation in terms of python design
and different operations so what he did
was built inside pandas a system for
having extension extensions in terms of
types and then building the diesels our
plugin so this is a separate library but
pandas now has this so everything like
category and everything else is now
moving to all this and now it's much
much easier to have course sometimes for
example probably you know that if in
pandas you have integers and you have a
missing value this becomes a float
that's quite annoying but integers non
values don't exist in the integer world
I was showing before how all things are
represented in zeros and ones there is
no zero sum want representation
representation for integers with not
so if you try to force that it will
still break it will say no when I can
represent this man as an integer eight
but because of this extension now it was
somehow easy and so how easy I mean that
everybody did that and I assume it was
easy for him was probably something
impossible for most of us but yeah now
this is still in master it's not yet
released but in the next version of
pandas you will have this version you
win eight that you will be able to have
these integer values we have matched
this I think was the more one of the
main complaints about pandas then there
is one of the herald Avella pairs
implemented at an extension type that is
mainly using it's a race here I'm
generating a million of strings that
it's a sperm sometimes ended with a comb
and sometimes ended with a exclamation
mark I'm counting how many of dynamics
and with an exclamation mark and I'm
going to time how much is that of course
it's one third because I'm writing them
without waiting and with this Fletcher
I'm able to represent the strings that
the strings are Python objects and are
very slow in pandas at the moment with
this Fletcher extension I'm able to
represent them with these Fletcher
string that disease this is our row this
is a stream and this is much faster so
if I do that this basically is giving
like forty percent of of time in seconds
248 milliseconds 268 this is still under
development I don't think it's ready for
production yet this Fletcher but it's
quite promising what what it's going on
some other stuff is happening and I'm
about to finish is the documentation
there is a major refactoring of the
documentation in terms of fixing the
contents making sure that every time you
are looking for a Python method for a
panda's method for data frame method or
or one of the functions you get proper
examples and that this is the plot kill
year it was done during a sprint and now
it has plot it has reference to other
interesting pages the parameters are
well-documented understo commentation
was in grade we're getting there but
it's still
a lot of work and also the style of the
panel's documentation page is not great
we are also changing that it is still
work in progress but hopefully we'll get
that soon there is not impugn does
itself and I'm almost finishing I know
I'm out of time already didn't psyche
learn but it was done by upon the score
developer so I think it's worth
presenting it as time this thing
now our cycle learn will implement these
will will have this make column
transformer it was quite tricky to in to
apply in pipelines functions or
transformers in the in the secular and
terminology different transformations
for single columns so if you're if
you're in scaling your data you were
scaling everything it was something in
vitro union that makes your code cryptid
it's totally impossible to understand in
my opinion so I actually implemented
something like this and I assume most of
you working with pylons and cycle then
implements some sort of of work around
to make sure that you are able to apply
apply transformations to each colony we
are working with iteration years data so
these make column transform in now it
will be included this is not yet release
it would be in cycle energy dot twenty
not sure when when that is being
released so now it's as easy a se to the
fare you apply the standard scalar and
to the to these two other variables this
you apply the one foot encoder and if
you deal with the one foot encoder you
will know that it didn't work for
Strings it will in this next name in
these new a new version so I think it's
really really amazing because I think
cyclone is really a brilliant project
and it's very very good but those were
the main two problems at least for the
kind of work and I'm doing so yeah
that's just like showing that that you
can then feed this pipeline and train
models and whatever
whether I'm running this month
we need to run both so yeah you get like
the the whole transformation with with
the age scale and the and the other two
what in call it this is more references
about all this working inside kill learn
and just to conclude the Panda one
roadmap in September were playing to all
religious 0:24 with these changes mainly
about the extension of race normal bug
fixes and that then at the end of the
year just releasing a no final version
before one dot all which will contain
all the deprecations we want to of
things with one to the brigade and then
one dot all which will be 0.25 but we're
all these a stuff it remove so whenever
you want to move to panda as one the
best strategy would be moved to 0 25
make sure that your production code
design show any warning of deprecated
things fix it if that's the case and
then you should be safe to fix that and
then after one that all we'll see what
happens but the commitment is not to
break things until for a while you want
to get involved in pandas development in
mention before I help organize these
this group here in London is a great
place when you want to get the start if
contributing to open source and
everybody's welcome if you are already
contributing everybody's welcome to
mentor that's probably more needed even
the new contributors if you want to get
involved more in the economical level
you can support non focus as I said in
focus issues like the legal entity that
represent all as an open source
community you can volunteer you can
donate and more important you can make
your company involved non focuses on
organizing has some it now for companies
that are using these tools and they are
critical for them so they can meet the
core developers and they can have
discussions about the roadmap so if
that's the case of your company you're
making huge use of all these tools just
try to get into these four oh man
maybe support me focus and of course a
if you want to get involved in any
otherwise just feel free to contact me
in the path or in the or in the Internet
that's a picture from Sify and that's it
from my side thank you thank you very
much mark so we have time for one quick
question before we go onto our linings
do we have one we have lots of questions
but everyone will be in the pub
afterwards you sir given that you
suggested the t-shirts you want to shout
your question
so the question is about these five to
ten million users who estimate that we
have weather therapy they're influencing
the development yeah for sure
you were mentioning get cap on
stackoverflow that's probably the main
way they influence that so yeah of
course there is a fit but look if you
look if you go to all get cup and you up
in an issue and you say this is low
where I want this or that of course
that's the starting point for the
discussion even for core developers
ourself this picture actually is the
first time that the core development
team met so most of them I think just
like always met Jeff well actually let
me just for the for the sake of fairness
let's Jeff was invisible is there is the
leader of the project there is there is
communication for example we cycle learn
we touch models projects like this we
check it repositories it's some sort of
analysis when we want to deprecate
something yeah there is some sort of
checking to the best of our knowledge
trying to yeah speak to users if that's
possible or just go to stack overflow
see who is asking about that
go get cup and see the projects it's a
bit not that trivial to want to eat cup
and start looking for for things but
yeah if if we see that everybody in each
cup is using a filter probably will be a
bit more reluctant to get rid of that so
yeah I mean the communication channels
are be tricky I mean it's like it's
million users it's impossible to talk to
them but yes we try to understand what's
the community using and what they and
their concerns and problems let's thank
okay
you